"Uncatchable", Alexandr Zhelanov
...
-Dafroza Gauhier,
quand on parle de vous,
on dit souvent
que vous êtes une chasseuse
de génocidaires rwandais.
Acceptez-vous
cette expression ?
-Bah, écoutez,
je n'ai rien demandé, je crois.
Ce sont les journalistes,
vous autres, qui avez
vraiment inventé
cette expression,
officialisée.
Moi, je n'ai pas...
Je me suis pas
levée un matin...
-On vous assimile, enfin,
on vous compare souvent à Serge
et Beate Klarsfeld,
parce qu'avec votre mari,
vous essayez de retrouver des gens
qui ont participé à ce génocide
au Rwanda. C'est une comparaison
qui vous convient ?
-C'est pas que ça nous convienne
ou pas. Encore une fois,
c'est un terme institutionnalisé
par les journalistes.
Mais il se trouve
que c'était un raccourci,
mais qui permet quand même
de faire comprendre au public
le travail qu'on fait
quand on poursuit des nazis
ou quand on poursuit
des génocidaires rwandais. Pour
moi, il n'y a pas de différence.
-Bien sûr.
Vous avez rencontré votre mari
au Rwanda, Alain Gauthier,
qui est français,
lui, il est coopérant,
il a connu le Rwanda
en qualité de coopérant.
Dans quelles circonstances
vous l'avez rencontré ?
-Alors, écoutez, il a enseigné
à Butare, à côté de Butare.
-Il est là, votre mari.
-Mais en tout cas,
il était prof et il enseignait
dans un établissement
où il y avait un de mes cousins,
Joseph,
et il y avait aussi ma soeur.
-Qui enseignait.
-Donc, en fait,
il était plutôt pote avec...
-Avec votre famille.
-Voilà.
-Vous, vous êtes ingénieure.
-Je suis ingénieure chimiste.
-D'accord. Alors,
le génocide du Rwanda,
c'est plus de 800 000 morts
en trois mois.
-Oui.
-En 1994,
d'avril à juillet 1994.
Et vous avez perdu une grande
partie de votre famille
dans ce génocide.
-Oui, je crois que,
quand on est Tutsi du Rwanda,
je crois
qu'on a énormément perdu.
La famille de ma mère, il n'y a pas
de survivants à ce jour.
-Combien de morts
du côté de votre maman ?
-Je ne sais pas si je les ai
comptés, mais 50, 80, 100.
Vous savez, aujourd'hui,
on ne compte que des survivants.
Parce que les morts, il y en a eu
tellement dans notre famille,
il y en a eu tellement.
Moi, j'ai quitté
le Rwanda en 73.
Et il se trouve qu'il y en a
qui sont nés après mon départ.
J'étais réfugiée politique,
je ne pouvais plus rentrer
et voilà.
Donc on n'arrive même pas
à compter les morts
tellement,
tellement il y en a.
Le berceau de la famille
de ma mère,
c'était
dans la région de Butare,
des oncles, des tantes,
des cousins, des petits-cousins.
Aujourd'hui,
j'ai personne.
-Que vous n'avez jamais,
jamais, jamais pu...
-Non, on a cherché.
-Pu retrouver.
-Non.
-Avec votre mari,
vous avez commencé
à vous mettre en quête justement
des génocidaires,
à essayer de faire la lumière
sur ces événements horribles,
tout à fait exceptionnels,
assez tardivement, longtemps après,
si je puis me permettre,
c'est au tournant des années 2000
que vous avez commencé à consacrer
beaucoup de temps à ça.
-Oui, c'est-à-dire que
le Collectif des parties civiles
a été créé en 2001.
-Ca, c'est l'association
que vous avez créée.
-Voilà.
-C'est le Collectif
des parties civiles...
-Pour le Rwanda.
-Voilà.
Donc on a créé cette association
pour se donner un cadre de travail,
un cadre pour pouvoir avancer,
pour pouvoir
se doter d'un outil
en quelque sorte,
mais dès notre retour en 96,
là où on comptait justement,
on essayait
de retrouver des survivants
de la famille
et des amis d'ailleurs aussi,
c'est là où on a commencé
à récolter des témoignages.
On est tombés sur quelques rescapés
de la famille,
quelques naufragés
et qui ont commencé
à nous raconter leurs récits.
Evidemment effrayants,
comme on peut le penser.
Et c'est à ce moment-là
où on a commencé
à vraiment écrire.
On a écrit, on a écrit.
97, on retourne, on continue
ce travail d'écriture.
-Vous avez recueilli
des témoignages.
-On avait des cahiers
pour recueillir des témoignages.
97, la matière commençait déjà
à être assez conséquente.
On a continué. 97.
98.
Et c'est réellement
autour de 2000 et 2001,
il y a eu le fameux procès
de Bruxelles
contre les quatre de Butare,
beaucoup en ont entendu parler.
-Les quatre génocidaires
de Butare. A Bruxelles,
en Belgique.
-Et il se trouve que je suis
très liée à cette communauté
rwandaise de Belgique,
c'est là où j'ai fait
une partie de mes études.
Et c'est là
où résidait mon frère,
un autre réfugié
des années 60,
qui m'a accueillie après 73.
Et il se trouve que, dès 94,
eux, ils se sont constitués
en collectif.
Et on a cheminé un peu avec eux
jusqu'au procès de 2001.
Et ça nous a donné vraiment
des ailes, de l'audace,
pour pouvoir se dire :
"Tiens, et si on créait
le collectif
"pour aussi essayer de faire
quelque chose en France ?"
-Revenons aux origines
de ce génocide.
Donc, ce génocide,
c'est en 1994 qu'il est commis,
c'est la majorité hutue du pays,
qui s'en prend
donc à la minorité tutsie,
dont vous faites partie.
Ces deux ethnies sont
des ethnies cousines finalement,
qui sont des ethnies bantoues.
Il y en a une, les Tutsis,
qui viennent plutôt
de la vallée du Nil,
les Hutus venant plutôt du sud.
Et...
il y a des causes qui sont,
alors, certains les expliquent
par la colonisation,
certains disent
que les Tutsis auraient été
avantagés par les colons.
Le Rwanda est une colonie
qui a d'abord été
une colonie allemande
avant d'être une colonie belge.
Et donc, à ce titre-là,
parce qu'ils auraient
toujours été favorisés
par les colons, eh bien, les Hutus
avaient un désir de revanche.
Qu'est-ce que vous dites
de cette version des faits ?
-Alors,
je peux pas faire l'histoire
du Rwanda en si peu de temps.
-Bien sûr.
-Mais ce que je peux vous dire,
c'est que les Hutus
et les Tutsis
ont toujours vécu en harmonie.
On vit sur la même colline.
On a des mariages mixtes.
On se connaît,
on échange des vaches,
on échange, on se marie
entre nous aussi.
Il faut dire
que cet antagonisme
entre Hutus et Tutsis,
c'est sûr, à l'origine,
vient de la colonisation.
-Vous confirmez ça.
-Je le confirme.
Le colon, pas allemand,
il est pas resté longtemps,
l'Allemagne a perdu ses colonies
après la Première Guerre mondiale.
-Le Rwanda et
le Burundi d'ailleurs
sont revenus à la Belgique.
-C'est ça,
sous tutelle belge.
Où le roi Léopold possédait
le grand Congo à côté.
Il se trouve aussi quand même,
dès 1900, on a
des missionnaires, on a
des pères blancs
qui arrivent au Rwanda.
Donc ils vont trouver une société
qui est très organisée,
si bien qu'ils se sont dits, on va
s'appuyer sur cette société-là
et sur ceux qui la gouvernent
ou ceux qui sont les organisateurs
de cette société.
Il se trouve que le Rwanda,
c'était un royaume.
C'était toujours autour du roi
et, à ce titre,
la Belgique, qui a repris
après l'Allemagne,
et les missionnaires,
qui sont arrivés
en même temps,
se sont tous appuyés
sur la société
existante, c'est-à-dire
l'organisation royale
existante.
-Et le roi était tutsi ?
-Le roi était tutsi. Le roi
était tutsi,
mais il pouvait y avoir aussi
des chefs, des sous-chefs,
qui étaient hutus à l'époque,
mais je pense
que ça a été exacerbé
par le colon belge,
qui a vraiment créé
cet antagonisme entre les Hutus
et les Tutsis,
en favorisant les Tutsis,
en leur donnant, enfin,
en exacerbant ces privilèges-là
et si bien que,
dès 1931 d'ailleurs,
cette société a été
complètement figée,
puisqu'il a été créé des cartes
d'identité hutues et tutsies.
Je pense que l'origine,
c'est vraiment 1931,
où on a figé cette société-là.
-Qu'on a essayé
de diviser...
-En Hutus-Tutsis, alors
que nous étions
des classes sociales.
-Donc vous confirmez
un peu ce que je disais.
Il faut le dire, en 1994,
le président, Juvénal Habyarimana,
revient d'un sommet international.
Lui, il est hutu.
Et son avion est descendu
par des...
-Missiles.
-Des tirs. Depuis Kigali.
Et on ne sait trop d'ailleurs
si ces tirs sont diligentés
par les Hutus afin justement
de justifier ce génocide
ou s'il a d'autres causes.
Ce qui est sûr, c'est que
cet événement est un événement
qui va ravager
les relations internationales,
parce que la France elle-même sera
mise en cause dans cette histoire.
Certains estiment que la France,
d'une certaine façon, a été,
a soutenu les Hutus
dans ce génocide.
Qu'est-ce que
vous dites de ça ?
-Là, il faut faire une petite
explication, revenir en arrière.
Il faut comprendre
ce qui s'est passé,
la montée de la violence
au Rwanda ne date pas de 94.
-Il y a eu des exactions avant.
-Ca date de 1959 où justement
pour, entre guillemets, punir
les Tutsis, on les a chassés
et du pouvoir et on les a chassés
aussi du pays.
Tout le monde n'était pas
au pouvoir. Il y avait des Tutsis
sans pouvoir.
C'était juste des Tutsis,
des citoyens ordinaires.
Donc, dès 1959,
justement le colon
qui a voulu favoriser
la majorité hutue,
mais pourquoi ça s'est passé ?
C'est-à-dire que,
dans les années 50,
vous connaissez,
vous savez
que les pays africains
ont demandé leur indépendance
et le Rwanda en faisait partie.
Le roi a demandé aussi
l'indépendance du Rwanda.
Et ça n'a pas du tout
plu au colon.
-Au colon belge.
-Voilà. Si bien qu'à ce moment-là,
il a commencé à se rebeller
et à favoriser les Hutus,
en disant d'ailleurs : "Vous êtes
beaucoup plus nombreux."
Voilà. "C'est comme ça
que ça doit être."
Donc le Belge a changé de main.
-Après avoir favorisé les Tutsis,
il a favorisé les Hutus.
-C'est là où commence
cette violence sans nom
contre les Tutsis,
les chassant du pays,
les tuant,
en faisant de la population
de la seconde zone,
des citoyens de seconde zone,
en le qualifiant
de tous les noms, un peu,
de serpent,
de tous les insectes
que vous pouvez imaginer.
-Vous en avez souffert ?
-Oui, on en a souffert.
Moi, je suis née peu avant
l'indépendance, en 54.
J'étais quand même jeune en 59.
Mais j'ai quand même vu,
je me suis vue
chassée de ma maison.
J'ai des souvenirs
plus ou moins précis,
pas complètement,
mais la violence, vous savez...
-Ne commence pas en 1994.
-Non.
-Mais bien avant.
-Un génocide ne peut pas
avoir lieu sans idéologie.
Cette idéologie de la haine
est montée dès 59,
mais en puissance.
Tout doucement,
tout doucement.
Quand on a commencé justement
à dire que le Tutsi,
il est mauvais en affaires,
il est malhonnête,
c'est un peu les mêmes clichés
qu'on dit sur les juifs.
-D'accord.
-Donc, du coup,
cette idéologie-là était
très, très bien ancrée,
surtout dans la classe
intellectuelle du pays.
Et, évidemment, là, on va passer
plusieurs détails,
on va arriver en 94,
où il y a eu
cette solution finale,
la seule manière
pour le Rwanda,
disaient ceux qui ont commis
le génocide,
la seule façon qu'il y ait la paix,
c'est la solution finale.
C'est de tuer les Tutsis
jusqu'au dernier.
-Il fallait les tuer
jusqu'au dernier ?
-Oui. S'agissant de la France,
vous en avez un peu parlé,
on peut revenir sur les accords
de coopération de 75.
Jusque-là, il n'y avait
pas énormément
d'attaches de la France
au Rwanda, mais dès 90,
avec l'amitié
du président Mitterrand
et du président Habyarimana,
il y a eu
quand même une aide,
une aide militaire,
une aide diplomatique,
des moyens,
en armes. Il y a eu
énormément de moyens qui ont été
donnés à l'Etat d'Habyarimana.
-D'après vous,
est-ce que la France,
le gouvernement français
de l'époque,
le président
François Mitterrand,
le Premier ministre
Edouard Balladur, à votre avis,
se sont-ils rendus,
comme le dit un journaliste,
Patrick de Saint-Exupéry,
ou comme le dit
Bernard Kouchner, qui parle
d'erreur criminelle, est-ce
qu'il y a une certaine passivité
au sommet de l'Etat français
face à ce génocide ?
-Moi, j'irais même au-delà.
Nous, les associatifs,
nous, les gens ordinaires,
les associations,
on n'a pas arrêté
de dénoncer,
de dénoncer, de dénoncer,
mais on n'a pas été
du tout entendus.
Je remercie
Patrick de Saint-Exupéry
qui a alerté très tôt,
dès 98,
à travers une série d'articles
publiés dans Le Figaro,
Bernard Kouchner aussi,
qui n'a pas non plus,
disons, qui ne s'est pas tu.
-Qu'on voit là en Somalie,
pour le coup.
-Oui, c'est ça.
Je pense que, là,
ils sont complètement validés
par le rapport de Monsieur Duclert
qui est sorti l'année dernière,
le rapport Duclert.
Il conclut comment ?
Il conclut par la faillite
de l'Etat,
la faillite de l'armée,
des responsabilités
lourdes et accablantes.
Alors, quand vous entendez
des conclusions comme ça
après un rapport de 1200 pages,
évidemment, il y a tout dedans,
la faillite de cet Etat.
Je vous conseille de le lire,
au moins le chapitre 7.
-Dafroza Gauthier,
votre action,
elle a abouti
à ce que des criminels soient
passibles de la justice
et il y a eu des procès.
Donc vous,
ceux que vous avez poursuivis,
vous les poursuivez en France.
Ce sont des Rwandais
qui se sont réfugiés en France
après le génocide,
pour fuir leurs responsabilités.
-Oui, fuir
la justice.
-Combien de personnes à ce jour,
nous sommes en 2022,
eh bien, ont pu être poursuivies
grâce à votre action ?
-Malheureusement
très peu. Pour l'instant,
on a eu cinq procès.
Trois ont été
définitivement condamnés.
-De gens que vous avez
retrouvés, vous.
-Oui, bien sûr. Trois ont été
définitivement condamnés
aux assises.
Un ancien militaire,
deux anciens maires,
25 ans pour le militaire,
la perpétuité
pour les deux maires,
et ensuite,
maire et ex-maire et là,
il y a eu un milicien
qui a été condamné à 14 ans,
le procès est en appel,
il a fait appel,
et là, un préfet
a été condamné à 20 ans,
mais il a fait appel aussi.
-Récemment ?
-Oui, récemment. Au printemps.
-Les génocidaires
qui sont poursuivis en justice,
certains, quand ils sont
retrouvés en France,
sont jugés en France.
La plupart ?
-Oui, alors, sont jugés
en France pourquoi ?
C'est selon la loi
de compétence universelle,
parce qu'ils sont
sur le sol français,
ils ont commis les crimes
à l'étranger sur des étrangers
et ils résident
sur le sol français.
Je crois que j'ai oublié
un élément, mais peu importe.
Mais pourquoi aussi
ils sont jugés ici,
donc selon cette loi-là, mais
parce que la France n'extrade pas.
Ca aussi, il faut le dire.
-Elle n'extrade pas. Elle refuse
de renvoyer, enfin, de livrer
aux autorités rwandaises
d'aujourd'hui des génocidaires,
parce qu'au Rwanda,
il y a un tribunal pénal
international
pour le génocide rwandais.
-Il y a le tribunal pénal
international qui a été créé
par les Nations unies en 94,
au mois de novembre,
et basé en Tanzanie,
c'est pas au Rwanda, mais
le Rwanda a jugé
par les tribunaux classiques.
-Beaucoup de personnes
ont été jugées ?
-Oui,
le Rwanda a jugé aussi
par les tribunaux Gacaca,
vous en avez peut-être
entendu parler.
C'est inspiré
de la justice traditionnelle,
parce qu'il y avait
tellement de criminels.
Ces procès-là en ont jugé
autour de 1800.
-Vous estimez
que l'Etat rwandais d'aujourd'hui
n'a pas occulté le passé.
Il a fait face.
-Non seulement ils ont fait face,
mais vraiment ils ont jugé.
Imaginez-vous,
s'il n'y avait pas eu
la justice,
je pense que les Rwandais
se seraient peut-être entretués
ou se seraient vengés ou etc.
Mais la justice,
ça permet d'enrayer l'impunité
et ça permet d'éviter
toute forme de vengeance.
-Et vous continuez, là,
votre mission,
j'ai envie de dire ?
-Vous savez,
il y a plus de 30 dossiers
sur les bureaux
des juges ici, à Paris.
Là, on a un procès
au mois de mai prochain
contre un ancien gendarme
et à la fin
de l'année,
un procès contre un médecin.
-Que pensez-vous du Rwanda
aujourd'hui, 30 ans après ?
Il est dirigé par un homme réputé
pour être assez autoritaire,
qui s'appelle Paul Kagame.
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez de votre
pays, qui s'est redressé de façon
assez impressionnante,
quand même ?
Il est montré en exemple
aujourd'hui. Beaucoup disent,
le Rwanda, pardon, ça paraît
complètement aberrant 30 ans
après un génocide,
c'est la Suisse de l'Afrique.
-Je pense que, réellement,
le monde est sévère
avec Paul Kagame,
sévère avec le Rwanda,
le monde n'est pas juste.
Est-ce que c'est parce
qu'ils nous ont abandonnés
au moment de 94
qu'ils sont obligés
de dire des choses ?
Le Rwanda a fait des efforts
à tous points de vue.
Le monde de la justice.
Ils ont jugé. Ils ont acquitté
aussi d'ailleurs.
La justice, c'est aussi ça,
c'est l'acquittement
et c'est condamner
et acquitter.
Il y a eu des efforts énormes.
Ils ont reconstruit
le pays à tous points de vue.
-C'est plutôt flatteur
de dire que vous êtes
la Suisse africaine, non ?
-Bien sûr,
mais il y a toujours un petit côté
"oui, mais", "c'est la petite
"Suisse d'Afrique,
mais en fait,
"c'est parce qu'il y a
un dictateur."
-C'est un homme
assez autoritaire, mais bon...
On dit que vous êtes
très proche de lui.
-Je ne sais pas.
C'est vous qui dites ça.
-Vous le connaissez ?
-Je connais mon président,
mais comme vous, vous connaissez
notre président ici,
mais je ne le connais pas
en tant que...
Je ne suis pas
l'intime de mon président,
mais je le connais.
-Vous êtes assez fière de la façon
dont ce pays s'est redressé ?
-Je suis vraiment
très fière de mon pays, je suis
fière de ce que mon pays a fait,
de cette bonne gouvernance,
qui a permis
que les Rwandais puissent
revivre ensemble, cohabiter.
-Aujourd'hui, Hutus et Tutsis
revivent ensemble ?
-Bien sûr. Ils vivent
sur la même colline
et ça le reste
depuis la nuit des temps.
On vit ensemble. Mon voisin peut
être tutsi, peut être hutu.
Voilà. On vit ensemble.
-Vous y retournez
régulièrement maintenant ?
-Oui, j'y vais souvent.
Nous y allons souvent
pour les besoins de la justice,
pour les besoins des enquêtes, etc.
-Alors, voilà,
Kigali, qui est la capitale,
avec ses gratte-ciel.
C'est un pays qui a
une croissance exceptionnelle,
un des plus dynamiques
d'Afrique.
-Bah, je pense que beaucoup de pays
après une guerre,
je crois
que ça s'est vu ici aussi,
après la Deuxième
Guerre mondiale,
il me semble qu'aussi,
l'Europe a reconstruit.
J'ai l'impression que les pays,
quel que soit l'endroit,
une fois que la paix
est revenue,
forcément, on se reconstruit,
sauf si on n'a pas de leadership.
-Paul Kagame,
il faut dire d'ailleurs,
j'ai oublié tout à l'heure,
qui est tutsi, lui.
-Oui, mais il est
le président des Rwandais.
C'est pas parce qu'il est tutsi.
Le Premier ministre...
Si on y va comme ça,
on est tous des Rwandais.
Evidemment,
il est connoté, parce que
c'est un ancien chef de guerre.
C'est lui qui a arrêté
le génocide
et ça, on n'en entend pas
beaucoup parler non plus.
-Le Front patriote rwandais.
C'est le FPR.
Qui existait déjà en 1994.
-Bien sûr. C'est eux
qui ont combattu
pour la libération du Rwanda
après le génocide.
Oui, c'est grâce à eux
qu'on a pu revivre, je pense.
-Aujourd'hui,
vous avez de la famille
qui est retournée
vivre là-bas ?
-Oui, les anciens,
comme beaucoup, hein.
Ceux qui étaient réfugiés au Congo,
ceux qui étaient
réfugiés en Tanzanie, tous les pays
limitrophes, le Burundi.
Moi, je suis du sud du pays,
donc une grosse partie
de ma famille était réfugiée
au Burundi. Ils sont rentrés.
-Et vous, vous voulez pas
retourner vivre là-bas ?
-J'y vis déjà pas mal,
je trouve.
Cette année, j'y ai vécu 5 mois
et demi, vous voyez,
on est au mois de novembre,
c'est pas... Je pense que je...
Oui... Je suis une intermittente.
-Vous êtes une intermittente
avec votre mari qui, lui, a fait
de ce pays sa seconde patrie.
-Oui, forcément, hein,
comme moi j'ai fait
de la France ma patrie
et je ne vais pas
me couper en deux.
Je suis aussi très fière
d'être française.
-Et donc, vous êtes
et française et rwandaise.
-Voilà. Oui, je peux pas,
j'ai pas envie de choisir
une culture plutôt que l'autre.
-Si je vous dis
Gaël Faye, ça vous dit quoi ?
-Bah, c'est notre enfant.
-C'est votre gendre.
-Oui.
-C'est un artiste donc,
musicien,
écrivain aussi.
Il a écrit un livre
qui a eu le prix Goncourt
des lycéens, "Petit pays".
Il travaille avec vous
dans l'association, non ?
-Oui, oui.
-Il consacre du temps à ça.
-Il est dans l'association,
il est secrétaire du Collectif
des parties civiles.
Oui, il suit les dossiers.
Oui, bien sûr.
-J'ai lu quelque part,
Dafroza Gauthier,
qu'en fait,
chez vous, il y avait
ni haine ni esprit de vengeance,
mais un souci de justice
dans votre action.
-Oui. Vous savez, si vous commencez
à vous venger,
ou si vous commencez à... Ca,
c'est pas la justice, en fait.
La justice, c'est...
Lutter contre l'oubli.
Contre l'impunité.
Mais c'est un travail sérieux,
c'est un travail du roi,
il faut la preuve.
La justice,
c'est toujours la preuve.
Sans la preuve,
personne ne peut être condamné.
-C'est la justice
qui motive votre action.
-Ah oui. C'est la justice et
c'est la lutte contre l'impunité,
parce que, quand on est tutsi
et qu'on a vécu au Rwanda
toutes ces années-là et qu'on n'a
jamais eu de justice,
euh... ça vous marque
toute une vie.
-Il y a pas de haine chez vous.
-Non.
J'ai pas le temps, en fait.
-Vous n'avez pas le temps.
-La haine, c'est quelque chose
qui peut vous ravager
et qui peut vous faire commettre
des bêtises
et qui peut aussi
vous inhiber
et vous prendre
toute votre énergie.
Alors, je n'en ai pas pour ça,
je vais la consacrer à la justice.
-Merci beaucoup,
Dafroza Gauthier.
-Je vous remercie
de votre invitation. Merci.